so there's the expected value I've
changed that now they asked me for
variance right so just like before
instead of working out the variance of
2x minus 4 change all the data and then
calculator
I'm just working out the variance as it
is and then doing whatever change is
necessary we'll look at that in a second
ok so variance again multiplying
probability each time and then ok take
your breath it's a value subtract the
expected value then square right so
there's my first value subtract my
expected value and then square this by
the way is a perfect example of when you
save that value save it into your
calculator so you don't have to write
2.85 2.05 do it five times
pop it into one of the variables that
you've got there and then you'll get it
okay I'm gonna finish writing it first
and then we'll get a value for you so
you do need to have that working that
it's important there's that one
probability value takeaway expected
value square probability value takeaway
expected value and then square last one
probability value takeaway expected
value and then square that's why we were
doing this with spreadsheets this around
it'd you say you already had a number on
this one oh that's okay no problem
someone can let me know once they've
finished writing and calculating what
they get
did you get something oh yeah
do calculate it that's you know we need
we need practice doing them or one make
sure we get it right I have a value I
just want to make sure that it agrees
with your one first year you got
something done all right you're not sure
which thing oh yeah yeah okay so what
did we say 2.85 that's the thing when I
say so assume you've done your
calculation and then it's there you go
shift stores right there and then you
pick a letter
a will do just tap on that and now
anytime you use alpha a it'll it'll do
that so for example I'll write this as
0.2 times one takeaway alpha a and then
you don't have to write 2.85 every time
easily did you get one point six okay
fantastic we've got a bit of agreement
here in us we also feed you guys yep
yeah eventually we will get there okay
now now we have the variance for the
data as it was first presented to us but
now they were asking a slightly
different question what is the variance
if we change the scale to X and then
change the origin take away four okay
come back to your table that we wrote
down before here it is right here's
variance okay
let's start with this one change of
origin does that have any impact on the
variance and the answer is no because if
you move all your data together it's
still just as spread out as it was
before or not spread out as was before
so I'm gonna kind of ignore this
takeaway for that all right I don't need
to worry about it but that to the change
of scale what effect does that have it's
gonna make my variance four times bigger
2 squared times bigger okay
and in fact I encourage you to write it
exactly like that it's going to be 2
squared don't go straight to the 4 cuz
this shows you know where the 4 came
from 2 squared times the original
variance like so so whatever this number
is I'm gonna multiply that by 4 say
again okay so what I've done is I'm
thinking about variance now for not the
original data as it was on the page but
now I'm thinking about well what happens
if I change the scale the data make
everything twice as big and also change
the origin so move everything downwards
okay
I noticed that you know when you change
the origin it doesn't affect the
variance at all when you change the
scale it does it changes it by the
square of whatever you're changing but
right so I'm changing it by double so
I'm gonna double squared has someone got
the answer for me already
is it a five-point something four times
that no 6 point what is it what six
point five one there yeah so there are
new variants okay now what I'd love you
to do is that's that's 23
I'd love you to try without quite so
much help on
over the page see if this wakes up tick
tick tick tick success okay so this is
just over the page okay
now you can see this stuff down here is
exactly what we were thinking about
before but let me remind you how to do
these earlier bits right Express em in
terms of M where I M and M on this set
of data it sits here underneath the two
hundy 4 4 so these are probabilities
right this is a discrete random variable
so what do you know about all the
probabilities that up to one very good
so when you write that this Plus this
Plus this equals one you'll be able to
do Part A ok for Part B it says given
the expected value of this starter set
not not this one this is X I figure out
x squared given that it's this then
solve for the value of n so what you
need to do is take all of your oh I left
my pencil down on the let's do this way
sorry this is messy we're now theme at
the expected value not of this but if x
squared so when you go ahead and do the
calculation
you're gonna you're not gonna put in 1
you're gonna put in 1 squared and you're
not gonna put in 2 you're going to put
in 2 squared and 3 squared and 4 squared
and so on go ahead and work out your
expected value but you know what the
answer is supposed to be right so you
can use that to then calculate N and
then calculate and see if I can get with
that nudge in the right direction we're
about to hit the bell but I would really
love while this is still fresh in your
brain will take a bit of a break later
but try and get this down now turn over
the page if you haven't already and see
if you can do 24 in your book
ok off you go